Hi, we hope you're now all excited to build
scalable applications using App Engine and the Google Cloud platform.
In this lesson, we'll get down to the nuts and
bolts of everything, and have you deploy your first code
to App Engine. This will involve an number of
different steps, but don't worry, we'll all do it in
a structured and orderly fashion to make sure you're on
your way to become a rock star App Engine developer.
So let's look at what we're going to do in
this lesson. First, we're going to look at the App Engine development
cycle and create an App Engine project where you can
upload your code. Then we're going to look at cloud endpoints that
allows you to create a backend that can work with
any frontend device technology. After that, we'll get you started with
a development environment where you develop code for App Engine. And
then, we'll introduce Conference Central, the application that we will build
out throughout this course. At the end of this lesson, you'll have a
working application running in the Google Cloud.
Isn't that exciting? Let's go, shall we?